l es français ne décolère par les règles
sanitaires imposées par l'exécutif ne
passe toujours pas d'autant plus que le
gouvernement veut transformer le
passionné et est en passe vaccinale
s'ajoutent à cela les récents propos sur
les non-vaccinés plutôt fleuri du
président emmanuel macron qui dit
assumer pleinement ses propos de quoi
peut être donner un nouveau souffle à la
mobilisation de ce samedi à plusieurs
rassemblements à travers tout le pays
rien qu'à paris il y en a quatre dont
celui sur appel des gilets jaunes cps de
catalani le départ où l'on retrouve
d'ailleurs notre reporter rester le
fasse
bon jour estelle alors quelle est
l'ambiance actuellement
[Musique]
eh bien écoutez amira le cortège vient
de démarrer direction 1 place de la
nation les gilets jaunes qui se sont
joints au mouvement de protestation
contre le pass sanitaires et le pass
vaccinale ils manifestent principalement
aujourd'hui contre le projet de passes
vaccinale qui pourrait entrer en vigueur
le 15 janvier prochain mais il ya aussi
des revendications liées au début je
suis du mouvement je propose d'écouter
les gilet jaune à qui nous avons pu
parler notamment l'organisateur de la
manifestation d'aujourd'hui
vraiment le pouvoir qui est en train de
mettre une pression contre les opposants
politiques et nous ici vous avez des
gens qui ont rien à gagner dans cette
lutte en termes financiers en termes de
postes on est là vraiment parce qu'on
est con ce gouvernement n'a rien à
gagner et en et l'opposition les gilet
jaune et citoyens en colère et on est
toujours là plus on avance dans le temps
et en fait puis on nous prive de liberté
moi ça fait deux ans que je suis en
télétravail et bah c'est long et ça
suffit ça a choqué une bonne partie de
la france
qu'un président en fonction en mer d'une
partie de la population
et qu'il ira jusqu'au bout bien sûr
qu'il ira jusqu'au bout cabano le
message qu'on va lui faire passer c'est
que nous aussi on ira jusqu'au bout et
que nous aussi on va continuer à
emmerder et c'est ça la stratégie voilà
pour les revendications du côté du
cortège vous le disais il s'était lancé
il y a quelques minutes depuis la place
de catalogne direction donc la place de
la nation
merci alain pour toutes ces précisions